selon cette quinzième en quête de l'unef
besançon se trouve en bonne compagnie
tout comme neuf autres villes
universitaires françaises dont bordeaux
lyon lille ou nantes besançon cumule en
effet cette année ou plutôt ses
étudiants une double augmentation
augmentation du loyer moyen d'abord le
premier poste budgétaire +2 42% par
rapport à la dernière rentrée soit un
loyer mensuel moyen de 381 euros
augmentation du prix des transports
ensuite que l' enquête signal comme
étant dans toutes ces villes supérieur à
la moyenne nationale à besançon les
étudiants déboursent en moyenne 280
euros par an dans les transports en
commun soit une augmentation de 1,0 8%
l'université de franche comté qui
rayonne sur cinq villes compte trente
mille étudiants dont un peu plus de 10 %
d'étrangers